I think Cameron loves being married
because he loves Daphne so yeah I love
my wife and I love my kids but I love
drugs and hookers drugs yeah exactly
[Music]
Cameron loves doing whatever he wants
but then he also knows anchored by his
wife the minute that that could
potentially be taken away from him I
think there's quite a lot of fear
I think that's sort of why the marriage
functions so well because the thing that
he needs is the thing that Daphne
thrives he's giving she really likes
taking care of him you know they really
love each other it's like a genuine you
can feel that yeah there's something
really there like built on a real
emotion yeah but then within that is all
that hyper dysfunction yeah I feel like
you sew your oats when you're young and
then you just you know you get it out of
your system I don't know
make sure it works like that
do you know I think it was it was tricky
Aubry and I
so at one point you know I'm supposed to
be rubbing her leg and I'm like yeah
yeah
it's real it's really hard balance to
find yeah I'm like it's so impossible
not to see this happening will and I
were both like are we seeing this I
think other than that we had a really
good time it was a lot of fun from what
I can remember
his moral compass is completely skewed
come on you can't begin me it looks like
that from my wife I don't care where is
my money I know okay just just relax
okay you're gonna get your money also
his sense of entitlement is so rich that
he thinks he should be able to do
whatever he wants you know that's kind
of almost the message isn't the problem
with the hyper wealth and classes he
thinks that he's entitled to everything
that he can take so there's sort of a
perfect match in that sense because on
the other than all the drugs and the
cheesing he's a pretty okay husband
other than being a [ __ ] right
[Music]
which White Lotus character would I pick
to take on vacation with me I think I
would take Coolidge
exactly
[Laughter]
um I take uh sweet Adam yeah that was
gonna be my next one I take Alby I'll be
I take I'll be anywhere
carry on for me yeah carry on I do
prefer carry-on luggage if I can
maneuver it it just feels so much more
seamless and I do love the feeling of
walking off the plane and just leaving
the airport yeah yeah I agree never to
return
I am definitely go with the flow I sort
of have an aversion to committing to a
plan I'm very much like see how I feel
when I wake up what do we want to do
today what about you I'm a bit of a
planner yeah because I hate getting to a
place and it disappointing me so I kind
of I get that you know I want it I want
to go to the place but in a way it's a
bit of a curse because nowadays you can
look anything up in the world and look
up 100 reviews on it yeah that's true
strange place we live in yes what a
[ __ ]
[Music]
foreign